mais d'abord emmanuel macron face aux
journalistes les grands axes de son
programme détaillé par marion belpech
après avoir défendu son bilan devant
plus de 300 journalistes emmanuel macron
dévoile son programme en pleine guerre
en ukraine il souhaite porter le budget
de la défense à 50 milliards d'euros
d'ici 2025 doubler le nombre de
réservistes et généraliser le service
civique universel c'est un des éléments
de la refondation du pacte si
essentielle entre nos armes et la nation
pêle mêle le candidat propose une
réforme des lycées professionnels des
états généraux pour l'information et une
loi sur l'installation agricole sur le
travail emmanuel macron vise le plein
emploi dans cinq ans et souhaite en
finir avec pôle emploi pour créer france
travail la volonté avec france travail
c'est d'avoir je n'aime pas tellement ce
terme c'est celui souvent qu'on emploie
de guichet unique mais un lieu où on
accompagne toutes celles et ceux qui ont
vocation à revenir à l'emploi de manière
beaucoup plus simple et où on met toutes
les compétences autour de la table on
les accompagne bilan de compétences
formation des formations en terme de
savoir être ou de savoir faire ou des
formations plus lourdes et
accompagnement vers le retour au travail
avec de l'adaptation ouvert le travail
totalement libre si je puis dire et dans
des conditions normales
cette réforme de france travail est un
élément clé pour gagner en efficacité et
permettent d'aller vers le plein emploi
il confirme le décalage progressif de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 65 ans
et propose une réforme du rsa sur
l'école et la santé le candidat concède
un bilan mitigé pour moi ce sont deux
immenses source d'inégalité aujourd'hui
on a beaucoup fait sur ces sujets on a
investi en matière de santé comme jamais
la nation n'avait investi depuis la
création de l'hôpital public nous avons
beaucoup investi sur l'école mener des
réformes très profonde et pourtant les
choses ne vont pas assez vite en réponse
le candidat propose pour l'école une
large concertation et un pacte nouveau
pour les enseignants dans le domaine de
la santé emmanuel macron souhaite
accentuer la prévention et s'attaquer au
problème des déserts médicaux d'abord et
b les médecins de ville comme les
dentistes pour qu'il puisse prendre
davantage de patients ce qui veut dire
généraliser ce qu'on a commencé à faire
les assistants médicaux pour tous
les infirmiers salariés subventionnés
dans les zones moins doté ce qui permet
de libérer du temps de médecins et de
confier à des paramédicaux 7h absolument
essentiel enfin le candidat a fait
plusieurs propositions pour améliorer
les finances de chacun modification des
droits de succession suppression de la
redevance baisse des charges pour les
travailleurs indépendants pensions
minimales pour les retraités à 1100
euros et être supplémentaire pour les
mères célibataires
et on débat autour de cette conférence
de presse du président candidat avec
françoise degois bonsoir vous êtes
éditorialistes essayiste et vous publiez
l'homme qui n'avait pas d'amis chez plon
et ça concerne directement emmanuel
macron alexis hager bonsoir bonsoir le
président du cercle de réflexion la
france audacieuse bruno cautrès
politologue chercheur au cevipof bonsoir
sur thomas bienvenue avec nous en duplex
en visio jean daniel lévy directeur
délégué chez harris interactive bonsoir
jean daniel merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation et lætitia cru pas
éditorialiste politique à mes côtés
évidemment comme chaque mardi et chaque
jeudi
peut-être je vous ai proposé à chacun de
choisir un extrait en revanche lui dis
donnez nous deux extraits on va nous en
choisirons voilà c'est ça c'est là la
cuisine de sens public donc on y viendra
dans un instant et peut-être un regard
un peu globale sur la prestation de du
président de la république et du
candidat puisque là c'était vraiment le
candidat qui s'exprimait sur le fond et
la forme prend soin de moi qu'est ce que
vous faites ressortir qu est-ce qu la
marque est prioritairement je veux jeu
mais je dois aucune différence entre les
manuels macron depuis cinq ans et le
emmanuel macron d'aujourd'hui on a bien
compris que voilà il est dans une
logique savez c'est comme dans le tour
de france et le maillot jaune qui veut
contrôler la course en se disant je fais
gaffe à toutes les échappées possible
mais moi je prends pas de risques moi je
considère en tant qu'éditorialiste
politique le pire des risques c'est ne
pas prendre de risque mais lui a priori
n'est pas du tout là dedans il a fait
une conférence de presse classique qui
ressemble au grand débat un peu
ennuyeuse très technique qui rentre dans
les moindres détails a pas vraiment de
vision globale c'est assez flou rien et
chiffré il donne beaucoup à droite avec
notamment la la reprise de cette mesure
qui est de laurent wauquiez le rsa vient
de l'intérieur je veux dire globalement
c'est un maquereau extrêmement sûr de
lui en sous titre ya marqué moi ce que
je vois c'est l'art elle ma réélection
c'est une formalité puisque toute façon
je suis déjà projeté moi même je me
projette après donc rien de mais je dis
moi ce que je dis c'est attention
campagne un peu paresseux j'ai trouvé
cette conférence de presse classique un
grand débat un peu paresseuse un peu
paresseuse avec c'est à dire mon votre
avis général est ce que le président
s'est effacé derrière le candidat
j'ai retrouvé plus tôt ou une tonalité
de candidats un peu comme le candidat de
2017 mais plus tempéré plus mesuré
peut-être moins start up nation que ce
qu'on avait en 2017 on voit quand même
que les années du pouvoir on laisse des
traces bien sûr sur toute personne qui
l'exercent j'ai trouvé intéressant la
première partie où il donnait les grands
axes on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord
mais j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait parce
qu'ils l'annoncent est vraiment bien au
delà du plan on voyait les idées qui le
portait la fois des idées un peu de
philosophie politique et décliné après
sur ces trois axes y compris avec le
pacte républicain
une france plus souveraine dans une
europe plus forte bon donc on voyait
bien en tout cas la structuration
intellectuelle du débat j'ai été étonné
après à certains moments du niveau de
granularité le niveau
et dans lequel il est allé non pas à
l'occasion des questions ou là on
retrouve la maîtrise habituelle qui est
quand même assez assez hors norme de de
pouvoir rentrer dans ce débat a fait ce
commentaire lors du grand débat là on
retrouve le grand débat mais en revanche
qu'était un peu désarçonnant c'est qu'il
allait à l'intérieur des problématiques
finalement dans le corps de son
explication et non pas uniquement dans
les dents les aux questions qui lui
étaient posées bruno cautrès on gagne
pas une élection une réflexion sur son
bilan est ce que est ce qu emmanuel
macron à donner du souffle c'est
suffisamment projetée dans dans dans
l'avenir et dans et donner l'espoir ou
en chanter l'avenir pour reprendre une
formule un autre ce qui est certain
c'est que la difficulté pour emmanuel
macron c'était de montrer qu'il était
fidèle à ses grandes lignes ces grands
fondamentaux et c'est vrai que on
retrouve quand même des fondamentaux du
maquereau nisme il ya des sujets sur
lesquels il est même quasiment pas de
surprise d'une certaine manière
tellement c'est cohérent avec le projet
dia cinq ans si je prends l'exemple par
exemple de obtenir une aide sociale en
compensation des heures de travail c'est
vrai que dès le début emmanuel macron ne
cesse de dire qu'il croit dans le
travail il s'était opposé fortement au
revenu minimum de benoît hamon en
2016-2017 donc on retrouve de ce
postulat des fonderies y ait une
cohérence et une cohérence qui me semble
assez incontestable donc c'est vrai
qu'on ne gagne pas sur le sur le sur le
bilan qu'il faut donner une perspective
on a une perspective qui est quand même
sur un certain nombre de piliers la
nouveau du maquereau nisme la question
de l'éducation alors évidemment
maintenant ils déclinent l'éducation
fort de son expérience il propose un
nouveau contrat entre le système
éducatif et l'état et on y revient dans
le détail notamment sur la méthode à des
demeures on retrouve quand même ce
fondamental de l'éducation qu'à un
élément très important dans lequel les
adhérents de la république en marge des
sympathisants crois beaucoup les
dimensions évidemment de souveraineté
européenne et de souveraineté nationale
depuis le début emmanuel macron essayé
d'expliquer qu'on ne peut pas faire l'un
sans l'autre que les deux vont ensemble
d'où son oxymore la souveraineté
européenne dont on trouve quand même pas
mal d'éléments ou emmanuel macron à
essayer de faire mentir ce qui voudrait
dire que le deuxième mandat d' emmanuel
macron eh bien on oublie ce qu'on avait
expliqué il ya cinq ans et puis on veut
quelque chose de deux nouveaux donc
c'est vrai qu'ils gagnent pas sûr on
gagne pas l'élection sur le sur le sur
le bilan il lui reste quand même alors
effectivement le niveau de généralité
parfois très importants et au contraire
à l'autre extrême on a un niveau de
micro détail qui rappelle emmanuel
macron du grand débat celui qui nous
montrait qu'il avait réponse à tout jean
daniel lévy est ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour dire qu'il n'a pas pris
suffisamment de risques ce qu'en dit la
macro il n'a pas pris énormément de
risques qu'un d'ailleurs si on les fait
l'exercice de couper son et de
uniquement regarder l image on aurait du
mal à savoir si on était face à un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle ou
imprécis dans et qui ferait une
conférence de presse classique d'une
manière générale il a vraiment cherché a
indiqué que ben macron 2 ne serait pas
très différent de ma croix et que ce
serait aux globalement la même ligne et
peut être avec quelques aménagements
notamment concernant la la retraite et
quelques aspects complémentaires s'il
prend des risques plus et de manière
assez faible c'est malgré tout
concernant certaines prises de position
dont on pense qu'elles vont être amenés
à faire réagir ça peut être sur la
retraite à 25 ans ça peut être également
sur la question du rsa dont on a vu je
te présente n'était pas complètement
dans le débat public et a été porté
aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron
probablement parce qu'ils le pensent
même probablement également avec une
vocation tactique on sait qu'aujourd'hui
le risque principal pour lui se situe
plus à droite qu'à gauche sur
l'échiquier politique et que en
cherchant à être le premier que ce soit
sur la question des retraites par
exemple ou sur la question de
l'absence d'assistanat à l'égard de ceux
qui vivraient au crochet l'ast est
française ce sont deux points qui nous
c'est sont assez audibles de la part des
électeurs de droite c'est le fait qu'il
soit le premier à prendre position là
dessus les empêche qu elle est en
quelque sorte
de lattaquié ou en tout cas de prendre
le leadership et d'un point de vue
d'opinion sur ces points là on va y
revenir dans un court instant puisque
c'est le premier district on diffusera
laëtitia ont dit les uns et les autres
que il ya quand même
côté macro 2010 est comparé à ma grande
gueule il n'a pas été aidé par des
journalistes parce que tous les
journalistes étaient sur ce sur toutes
les questions j'ai eu le sentiment
démarré comme ça en 2017 vous ai dit ça
et puis finalement ce que vous êtes le
même homme et oui à croire que
finalement les journalistes et c'est
assez fréquent préparent leurs questions
en amont c'est à dire que ce qui était
frappant c'est qu'il n'ya eu quasiment
aucune question sur le programme déroulé
par sur ce qu'ils venaient d'être
présentés qui venaient d'être présentés
il déroule un programme pendant une
heure et demie alors ils multipliaient
détails ça c'est la technique de
l'étouffement des journalistes à dire
qu'il est voilà ils déversent un
programme avec moult détails en a pas le
temps de digérer donc finalement on pose
la question qu'on avait qu'on avait
préparé en amont et c'est vrai que tout
tournait autour de qui êtes-vous
aujourd'hui et qu'est ce qui change par
rapport à 2017 et lui a trouvé la
réponse puisqu'il dit mais il n'y a pas
de changement c'est un changement de
méthode dans la continuité et donc s'il
se représente pour devant les français
c'est bien pour continuer ce qu'il a
planté le mandat qu'il a déjà fait donc
qui a été empêchée par beaucoup de crise
moi je suis pas d'abord la conférence de
presse emmanuel macron entre ressemble à
celle de nicolas sarkozy en 2012 quand
il présente son bilan si la même le mas
triade emmanuel macron c'est la même que
celle de nicolas sarkozy c'est le job et
où les ces espèces de comment il reste
de mythification d'un maquereau qui
serait capable d'avoir réponse à tout
c'est un peu fatigant parce que ça
masque en réalité le flou moi ce qui m'a
frappé quand même aujourd'hui c'est que
mon sentiment mais en règle générale
tous les candidats sont comme ça il
combine âge alors là vraiment alexia ça
devrait vous convenir on claque les
milliards comme ça je j'écoutais les
investissements on va investir en gros
on est plus d'argent dans les hôpitaux
on met plus d'argent dans l'éducation
mais plus d'argent partout mais en
réalité et je suis d'accord avec
jean daniel lévy je suis absolument
d'accord avec lui la réalité c'est à
droite tout genre alors absolument tous
les signes pour continuer à dépecer
valérie pécresse je termine thomert à
tel point qu'il ya eu un moment terrible
dans cette conférence de presse où un
journaliste lui dit mais vous pourriez
prendre valérie pécresse compromis ni
ses réponses pourquoi pas ça c'est la
leur au momment de l'étouffer c est ce
qui est va dans votre sens c'est
effectivement ce passage où il détaille
son programme pour ce qui concerne la
réforme du rsa on écoute emmanuel macron
il y aura dans cette réforme
l'obligation de consacrer 15 à 20 heures
par semaine pour une activité permettant
d'aller vers l'insertion professionnelle
soit formation en insertion soit
d'emploi et d'être mieux accompagnée de
dire y'a pas simplement une prestation
mais aussi un accompagnement et au fond
ce que je souhaite faire avec le cette
réforme du rsa c'est exactement ce que
nous sommes en train de déployer depuis
quelques semaines avec le contrat
d'engagement jeunes pour les 18 25 ans
la réforme du revenu de solidarité
active vous dites c'est ses banquiers
cdu wauquiez c'est du voc essai de la
droite la plus dure c'est véritablement
comment dirais-je vous savez il ya
quelque chose qui arrive je vais vite
pardonné moins dans la macro ni ya
maintenant cette idée qui est très
démagogue et populiste que chaque droit
doit s'accompagner dans de voir sa vie
on va faire un peu d'histoire
l'abolition des privilèges c'est
l'aristocratie qui exige qu'on a mende
qu'on amendes les droits des citoyens qu
on lit que ça colle aux devoirs et c'est
la constituante qui s'opposent en disant
un droit c'est un droit c'est d'abord un
droit ce n'est pas d'hier que les gens
sont des irresponsables mais un droit
est-il aliénable il ne peut pas être
accolé là on est dans montmagny ce genre
de concept tranquillement ça veut dire
que les gens qui sont au rsa sont des
grosses feignasses sur les professeurs
ça veut dire que ces professeurs vous
avez vu ils vont être payés en gros
mérite à travailler plus pour gagner
plus les profs sont des feignasses et on
va comment dirais-je augmenter les
meilleurs il ya tout ça dans ce discours
mais c'est fait avec tellement de
gentillesse avec un joli golf qui vient
si joli sourire que tout le monde se
fait prendre pas tout le monde 30% des
français pour le moment mais peut-être
que si on change moi je vais je vais
peut-être vous amener un élément peut
être un argument qui s'opposent alors
peut-être que laurent wauquiez elle a
défendu dans la majorité des manuels
macron il ya une personne qui défend
c'était oui les que les droits vont avec
des devoirs c'est olivier becht on peut
pas dire qu'il soit vraiment wauquiez
briller becht il est président du groupe
qui est agir à l'assemblée nationale
c'est un centre-droit et il l'a défendu
la fait une conférence de presse pour
expliquer ce principe sur le savez tous
ces sujets alors non mais c'est
peut-être aussi disent aussi
bien évolué depuis
vie dossier avec marc parlera le soir du
10 avril sur les agents de la société
sur ce thème non mais c'est vrai qu'il y
ait aussi s'ils ont évolué mais aussi un
jeu évidemment politique qui est
d'essayer d'aller couper l'herbe sous le
pied parce que on est dans une
cartographie politique est tellement
mouvante à 25 jours évidemment là
c'était l'occasion pour emmanuel macron
d'essayer de deux posé des banderilles
sur une situation qui est en train de
beaucoup évolué mais moi vous voyez
d'habitude comme vous le savez ce sont
surtout les sujets économiques que je
suis mais c'est pas ça qui m'a intéressé
aujourd'hui dans cette dans cette
conférence de presse en fait j'ai été
beaucoup plus attiré par
le discours du candidat sur la partie
agricole sur l'agriculture vraiment et
puis également sur les déserts médicaux
pour des raisons différentes sur les
déserts médicaux dit nous et puis
ensuite on verra l'extrait agricole
d'accord alors pour les déserts médicaux
pourquoi parce que j'ai trouvé qu'à la
fois évidemment ça après la passe que
vides tout ce qui touchait à l'hôpital
évidemment on l'a tous ressenti on sait
que c'est un des points sur lequel il y
à vraiment il y aurait besoin d'une
suite à ce premier ségur qui n'a pas
réglé le sujet donc le président parlait
de de la question du sens pour les
professionnels mais au-delà de ça ce qui
parle à tout le monde vraiment ce sont
les désarmer ou parce que il en a à
paris il y en a dans les territoires
bien sûr mais il ya moi j'ai entendu
quand on tombe et là la journée des
libertés locales mardi c'était diffusé
en direct sur notre antenne d'ailleurs
et manama qu'on n'y était pas oui tout
comme eric zemmour beaucoup de candidats
sont sur cette ligne là 2
d'obliger on va dire les seuls les
élèves les internes en quatrième ou
cinquième année de faire une idée
d'aller haut rhin déserts médicaux enfin
il y en a au moins quatre ou cinq sont
des déserts médicaux je vous parle pas
du désert médical sur le point de vue
technique je ne parle par rapport à
l'empathie oui que ça donne et puisque
réussi ou pas mais en tout cas on est
sur une thématique qui n'est pas
forcément vous êtes d'accord qui n'est
d'habitude pas explorées par le
président et je trouve que là ils
allaient sur cette partie là voilà non
pas sur l'hôpital qui est structurelle
et institutionnel mais plus sur ceux qui
parlent au quotidien en français
marqueurs de droite avec l'heure et ça
empathie marquer
le coup agriculture on y vient par
donald tusk sur cette question on touche
à vraiment un point qui est assez
fondamental parce qu emmanuel macron
essaye de capter quelque chose qui est
dans les jeux de logique de l'opinion
aujourd'hui au fond il ya deux thèses
qui s'opposent une première thèse qui
consiste à dire les raisons pour
lesquelles les individus ne peuvent pas
toucher les fruits de leur travail c'est
les grandes injustices et les grandes
inégalités ya des obstacles
insurmontables et donc pour compenser
ces obstacles il faut des aides sociales
c'est la philosophie politique de la
gauche élèves annuel marquant il nous
propose une autre facette qui est qu'au
fond les aides sociales certes c'est
intéressant maintenant faut-il les
mériter et donc on a la question du
mérite et cette question du mérite et
obsédante en france on voit que beaucoup
de candidats à cette élection
présidentielle tourne autour de cette
question eric zemmour ne parle pas
d'autre chose aussi d'une certaine
manière que de 7,9 à la droite de
l'échiquier au
delà on voit que il ya dans tous les
pays européens des forces politiques de
droite qui tourne autour apave parfois
même dans certains pays d'europe du nord
en suède par exemple donc cette question
les aides sociales ok mais ça se mérite
et la question de caisse que qu'est-ce
que tel individu qui accèdent à tels
bénéfices at-elle aides sociales
qu'at-il fait pour le mériter s qui
s'est retroussé les manches est-ce qu'il
en a vraiment besoin c'est une question
qui aujourd'hui mais renault pour vous
êtes vous à la spécialiste de l'opinion
publique et vous voyez bien quand
emmanuel macron a mis en place la
réforme du chômage eux mêmes s'attendait
l'exécutif s'est dit ça va faire des
remous pas possible y avoir des
manifestations regarder l'opinion
publique rien encéphalogramme plat donc
ça veut bien dire que l'opinion publique
et on le
constate si vous voyez bien qu'en fait
finalement ce qu'ils proposent emmanuel
macron c'est plutôt que c'est ça la
philosophie plutôt que de ne rien faire
et de toucher le rsa reste est inséré
dans la société en vous rendant utile
chez et ne pas décrocher voilà c'est
aussi ça y'a pas que du négatif non moi
je la perds mais aussi de restriction du
cevipof on demande si les chômeurs se
retrousser les manches pour était
vraiment retrouvé du travail 30 majorité
des français disent oui si faisait des
sceaux à l'épaule à moi là dessus pour
dire que le manque de réaction n'a rien
à voir avec le sujet il ya une aboulie
général dans ce pays qui parce que en
plus de ça vous savez ce que disait
bergeron faut donner du grain c'est pas
un berger corse et blondel il faut
donner du grain à moudre aux syndicats
les syndicats soient écrasés d'abord par
le quinquennat de hollande que moi j'ai
défendu j'ai participé en plus et
j'étais tout à fait contre ça et et part
parce qu'à kedallah par ivana de macron
avec sa gestion verticale et corps est à
moi il s'en fout donc je ne pense pas
que l'idée de voir se révolter les gens
est un marqueur pour dire qu'ils
acceptent ou pas je pense qu'il ya une
un bullygeois emploi vraiment se perdait
dans les enquêtes françoise si je la
machine parce que les normes et demi
mais enfin si
et moi je devais terminer je crois pas
qu'une majorité de français parce que
les chômeurs sont des feignasses c'est
parce que bruno cautrès a dit c'est pas
du tout ce qu'il a dit je pense que
passer vos si c'est vous dites que les
français considèrent qu'elle mérite moi
je crois pas je pense que ça c'est dans
notre cas c'est un aspect de la
situation mais je ressens alors même que
les français ressentent aussi on a
bouclé jamais abordé oui pardon pardon
vous interrogez c'est bien andré
bergeron tant qu'il y aura du mal à la
tête j'ai vérifié rapido ce que je
pensais je pensais que vous aviez raison
et c'était bien brest a aucun souci je
suis là pour ça aussi et alors la
souveraineté alimentaire et les
propositions des mails mâcon sur ce qui
concerne l'agriculture on les écoute
tout de suite je veux ici rendre hommage
à tous nos agriculteurs ils ont nourri
le peuple français pendant la crise et
durant cette pandémie nos agriculteurs
l'ensemble aussi des salariés du monde
de l'agroalimentaire
ont été absolument exemplaire et n'ont
cessé de travailler pour nourrir les
françaises et les français plus
largement nourrir les européens
nous avons à cet égard
le vrai pour continuer à transformer
notre agriculture
produire continuer à produire aller vers
plus de qualité encore plus de circuits
courts plus de bio est donc tout ce qui
a été au coeur des lois et gally main et
galim 2d stratégie portée par le
ministère sera poursuivie faut de la
constance et une approche par filières
comme nous l'avons eue durant les années
qui viennent quand même petit chat dans
la gorge connu plusieurs saisons dans
ces 90 minutes
deux orientations ça doit être ça
pourquoi ce choix alors ben écoutez pour
une raison totalement personnelle
d'abord parce que j'ai repassé un bac
pro agricole il ya trois ans j'ai que je
démarre et que je démarre ma première
année d'exploitation tout petit et donc
ce que je vais vous dire tout simplement
c'est que pour monter une à rl je vois
exactement ça me parle tout ce qui est
là derrière parce que c'est le prix des
engrais enfin donc voilà la raison pour
laquelle ça m'a intéressé et je trouve
que pour vous les dire que s'est nourri
de l'expérience de l'agriculteur abbas
qui voit la patte de julien de normandie
de toute façon très clairement qui est
un excellent ministre de l'agriculture
et on voit des gens qui
traditionnellement était plutôt sur un
prisme l air classiques agriculteurs qui
trouvent que le ministre enfin il ne
connaît de de quoi il parle voilà et
donc ça ça fait quand même une très
grande différence est ce que j'ai trouvé
très intéressant c'est que du si on
prend du recul par rapport à la
philosophie politique c'est finalement
là on est vraiment sur une une politique
de la réalité par rapport à cette crise
ukrainienne bien sûr mais ce qui est
très important c'est qu'en fait vous
avez eu au niveau européen quand on
allait quand il a mentionné un form to
work
on est véritable delà de la ferme à la
fourchette marc dont on est
véritablement sur un projet qui était un
peu idéologique quand même puisque on
devait aller vers moins d'engrais moins
de pesticides plus de jachères et plus
de bio sauf qu'avec ça en réalité on a
moins de volume et donc on produit moins
et aujourd'hui où en plus vous avez la
crise de l'ukraine ce sont des
problématiques extrêmement opérationnel
qui se la campagne agricole des marlins
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on plante dans les
champs et donc j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement intéressant de voir qu'en
fait le président le candidat
s'engageait sur une évolution en fait
par rapport à ce que propose aujourd'hui
l'union européenne c'est pas gagné 1
parce que ce qu'il propose là ce n'est
pas ce que propose l'europe donc il dit
il faut et il a raison de ce point de
vue là je pense conserver évidemment la
souveraineté ali en terre mais la
souveraineté alimentaire ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que quand vous avez
des jachères banon il faut en fait recul
tv derrière donc on vous voit bien le
croisement entre la micro et la macro
politique et je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant tient sur l'europe peut-être
votre regard jean daniel lévy on peut
considérer que l'image de l'union depuis
trois semaines a changé dans l'opinion
en france est ce que vous pensez qu'elle
je vous vois hocher la tête donc est ce
qu'on pensait que ça pète durable ou
peut-être que c'est sur évalué
d'ailleurs
elle a un peu progressé elle a un peu
progressé elle n'a pas considérablement
évolué au cours de ces dernières
semaines ça mais parfois du temps en
fait on efface comme une institution qui
a une vie assez ancienne et donc on sait
que les images sont souvent assez assez
lourde je pense qu'il faut rappeler que
la troisième motivation vote à l'égard
d' emmanuel macron au cours de la
dernière élection présidentielle c'était
la question européenne que il avait fait
distribuer des drapeaux dans ses
meetings qu'il en avait tiré un bénéfice
d'ailleurs au moment de du débat et des
élections européennes de 2019 ou sa
liste était arrivée en deuxième position
juste derrière celle du rassemblement
national et que d'une manière ou d'une
autre le fait que emmanuel macron soit
amené à parler d'europe le fait qu'ils
donnent le sentiment qu'il est impliqué
dans l'europe et qu'ils cherchent à
faire en sorte que l'europe puisse avoir
un poids plus important
n'apparaît pas comme étant une forme
d'incongruités en tout cas auprès du
coeur de son électorat qui ait
l'électorat aujourd'hui le plus pro
européen et guy quasiment le seul
électorat qui est aussi unie derrière la
question européenne
est-ce qu'il arrive aujourd'hui à
bénéficier en fait d'une forme d'image
qui serait profondément amélioré de
l'europe c'est pas tout à fait à ce
qu'on observe ce n'est pas tout à fait
non plus cette dimension qui est donné
on a plutôt en fait le sentiment que
l'europe est capable de pouvoir réagir
en cas de crise mais pas toujours être à
l'initiative telle qu'elle peut être
attendu d'une manière générale de la
part des citoyens français notamment on
ouvre un chapitre sur le la forme
pourquoi emmanuel macron at il choisi ce
format est ils ont hésité ils ont hésité
entre une adresse aux français à des
citoyens même un courrier simplement
envoyé et puis se sont dit il ya une
conférence de presse pourquoi y en a
plusieurs déjà d'une vous l'avez vu
c'est encore en cours c'est assure une
multi diffusion sur toutes les chaînes
d'info alors un temps d'antenne jeu ça
fait combien de temps maintenant ça fait
trois-quatre 15 heures il a commandé
magie nécessairement barkat presque
quatre heures sur trois quatre chaînes
il va falloir
beaucoup de meetings dans les prochains
jours sur les chaînes d'info je vous le
dis en tout cas selon lui on est à trois
semaines du premier tour c'est toujours
bon à prendre sans trop d'efforts
ensuite ça permet de démontrer qu'il est
qu'ils acceptent le débat parce que
selon ses termes ça c'est sa définition
du débat c'est une fois devant les
français soient devant les journalistes
devant les français nous la montre à
poissy il y retourne demain à pau et là
bas ils montrent qu' il n'a pas peur des
journalistes questionnements et puis et
puis des raisons concrètes 1eres trois
semaines donc trois week-ends pour
tracter demain il y aura un programme
qui va être commencé à distribuer de
huit pages dès la semaine prochaine 24
pages sam est envoyé dans toutes les
boîtes aux lettres des français et je
vais un tout petit peu mauvais esprit
pour finir je pense aussi que c'est une
une façon de c1 carpet bombing c'est à
dire que en fait c'est un rouleau
compresseur avec moult détails qui ne
permet pas aux journalistes de respirer
et donc ça lui permet de dérouler son
programme un peu sans risque et il évite
toutes les questions piège parce que il
n'y a très peu qui peuvent réagir dans
un livre d'art est ce qu on a évoqué
tout à l'heure françoise degois dans
votre livre vous dites que il s'est
beaucoup trompé emmanuel macron dans la
façon sa façon de s'adresser aux
français bien sûr oui je pense qu'il a
il là la plus grande correction et
jean-daniel sera je suis certaine et
bruno d'accord avec moi la plus grande
correction qui pourrait opérer c'est son
attitude savez dans le pays dans le
monde à causes aux saxons que j'aime
beaucoup et en israël on dit toujours
life is attitude' falla la vie c'est
l'attitude gouverner c'est l'attitude à
la macro a théorisé et je l'expliquerai
rien à mon bouquin ça c'est pas moi qui
l'inventé cetc les gens les déçus les
amoureux déçus du vin chronique qui a
terrorisé la caresser la gifle du gie
foutu car est ce sujet en fait on a
passé un quinquennat ces conseillers qui
lui avait dit ça
mais ça c'est toute la streif savez
c'est toute la stratégie strauss kahn
fuchs et compagnie on connaissait par
coeur tout ça pour dire que on a passé
le quinquennat en gros à soi engueuler
en gros 1 et puis de temps en temps se
faire caresser dans le sens du poil donc
finalement la seule attitude mois que
j'attendrais d'emmanuel macron c'est pas
son blabla avec ces colifichets vous
parliez d'agriculture cgj travailler
mais ils savent agriculture alim de et
aligne trois régal in 2 c'est un échec
c'est à dire que les prix n'ont pas et
ils ont hélas pas réussi à faire plier
les centrales d'achat pour créer de la
valeur et enrichir les paysans et les
agro donc tout ça est un joli village
potemkine moi ce que j'aurais attendu
parce que les journées je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec vous laetitia je
pense qu'il maîtrise parfaitement les
dossiers des malades macro là il ya un
très belle image un beau village
potemkine qu on ne bouscule pas mais la
réalité c'est est ce que lui a changé
est-ce qu'on va avoir le même emmanuel
macron qui dès 22h30 le soir de son
élection marche dans la cour du louvre
exerce un pouvoir autoritaire et
verticale et comment dirais-je et il n'a
pas ouvert la casse compassion moi je
veux bien qu'on m'explique tout ce qu'on
veut il est très gentil et c'est la
réalité c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
entre lui et ce pays qui ne s'est
toujours pas créés
françois là mais c'est pas le pays en
entier je pense que l'angle mort des
manuels macro et d'ailleurs c'est assez
symptomatique parce que dans chaque
débat on parle toujours des agriculteurs
oui c'est le premier secteur de
l'économie française mais c'est un pour
cent de la population l'angle mort d'
emmanuel macron ce sont les classes
populaires les classes moyennes tous
ceux qui vivent dans les zones blanches
les banlieues et ça il n'aura jamais
on n'est pas des anneaux ou dit la
france entière ils me sont pas là je
pense que l'on ne s'adresse aux
entreprises il s'adresse à donner moi je
pense qu'il est il est formidablement
aimé par la france qui l'a bien par ce
qu'on appelle le bloc élitaire dont
d'ailleurs mais il ya une majorité
silencieuse qui valide ce
que je veux dire c'est que le bloc
élitaire sénoufo jauzion c'est la france
qui va super bien c'est les livres m'ont
bien dit c'est chic c'est même à
l'anachronisme ne pas être macro nist
quand on est dans une situation moi je
pense qu'il parle à cette france là les
aviculteurs 1% peut-être mais en terme
d' influence s'est encore accélérée
bruno badré lié on avait un débat à la
suite des annonces du plan de résilience
économique et social par le premier
ministre et les économistes étaient
présents disait il et les chiffres ne
mentent pas l'insee il ya quand même une
progression du pouvoir d'achat pour une
majorité des français même si
effectivement il ya 6 millions de
pauvres il faut pas les oublier donc
oui pardon dollars mais peut-être que
finalement cette réalité-là économique
elle elle se retrouve aussi dans la
perception par les français du
du candidat macron d'ailleurs il a
insisté à cet après midi sur ce point en
disant on va continuer les baisses
d'impôts oui j'en ai même fait plus que
ce que j'avais probyn crise et j'ai déjà
tout ça donc on va continuer les baisses
d'impôt dans quelles fonctions il veut
toujours montrer qu'il a redonné du
pouvoir d'achat de suppression de la
taxe d'habitation bientôt de la
redevance télévisée
donc effectivement c'est un élément très
important pour emmanuel macron alors
ceci dit c'est vrai que tous les
économistes montrent que le pouvoir
d'achat a augmenté mais curieusement ça
ne se répercute pas de la même manière
sur tous les français la perception de
la période de la faillite
du plus la perception subjective malgré
les améliorations à l'économie va pas
mal le taux chômage etc mais il ya
toujours deux camps qui s'opposent dans
la vision des manuels macroule quand
défection de la france qui va bien
qu'ils aiment beaucoup emmanuel macron
et qui aiment ce personnage tel qu'il se
présentait encore aujourd'hui finalement
quelqu'un qui a qui projette l'idée
d'une france qui peut un jour être
réformé et emmanuel macron est au
service d'une sorte de mission
impossible qui est l'impossibilité de
réformer un pays qui ne veut pas être
réformé emmanuel macron ses soutiens
adore cette image de ce cet homme jeune
talentueux courageux qui essayent de
réformer le pays impossible
voilà est posée il ya toujours une
partie de la france qui regardent
emmanuel macron avec un énorme point
d'interrogation a dit ne nous ressemble
pas il nous comprend les stations peut
pas nous comprendre et de nous rendre à
paris surtout il ne comprend pas ce
panneau de contrôle il ne nous
comprennent pas je jette de la parole à
jean daniel lévy tout de suite sur
aujourd'hui reste très haut dans les
sondages et emmanuel macron mais bon il
reste plus de 3 semaines 2 de campagne
qu'est ce qui pourrait le faire
décrocher on était sur la thématique du
pouvoir d'achat et puis finalement alors
pardon aux françoise mais je vous pique
un peu ludique vous évoquez avant que le
débat
et
si finalement ils pillent les ide et au
second tour il arrive en tête avec je
sais pas à 23,24 on pourra presque se
dire que c'est décevant par rapport aux
autres en tant qu elle il est
aujourd'hui voyez ce qu'on veut dire des
choses oui je veux qu'on compare souvent
en fait les performances regardez son
âge et je pense qu'il faut quand même le
général comparer les résultats
électoraux par rapport aux résultats
électoraux en taille donc rappelé
effectivement qu'il avait réuni 24 % des
suffrages au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 ce qui peut
aujourd'hui faire que les 30%
actuellement kim tillie sont promis dans
le cadre des intentions de vote soit
amené à réduire ce sont deux aspects
soit un aspect un peu de démobilisation
de son électorat au conseil et au regard
des cétacés est singulier notamment
lorsqu'on compare par exemple électorale
de nicolas sarkozy que des électeurs qui
votent pour emmanuel macron ne sont pas
des fans d' emmanuel macron ils ont un
côté rationnel poser froid parfois et
pas forcément cette dimension
d'enthousiasmé de passion et qui
traverse en tout cas par le passé les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle et
les motivations de vote de leurs
électeurs le deuxième aspect on sait que
emmanuel macron peut aussi être sont
plus parfaite ennemis et on a fait
référence août à leur ensemble de
petites phrases qu'il a pu sortir en
janvier dernier notamment parlé de du
fait de la merde et les français qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés et que dans ce
contexte là ça a créé des entailles en
tout cas d'un point de vue d'opinion pas
toujours d'un point de vue d'intentions
de vote mais d'un point de vue d'opinion
il reste trois semaines et on sait que
ce type de phrase ce type de position ce
type de perception qui peut être perçu
comme étant soit le président des riches
ce quoi éventuellement un président
arrogant peu entaillé assez fortement
les motivations de bottes d'une partie
de ses électeurs ce qui était surprenant
aussi c'est que alors j'ai pas vu de
leur reste des questions mais pas une
question sur les gilets jaunes qui est
le gros gros boulets aux pieds des
manuels macron et qui est le feu est
encore là il est bien sûr les cendres
sont encore fumantes ya déjà les jaunes
sur les ronds-points il y a commencé en
bretagne
commencez à des blocages les routiers
qui veulent faire des opérations
escargot donc tout cela on le voit
presque plus on le constate au quotidien
fin d aucune aucune question qu'une nuit
nous reste un peu moins de cinq minutes
dans ce débat bono cautrès on va on va
regarder ensemble extraits que nous
avons choisi ensemble on a parlé des
institutions vouliez un extrait sur ce
thème là le seul ce moment où le
candidat macron parle de territorialiser
les politiques publiques
territorialisée davantage notre action
publique et permettre aussi de remettre
de la matière grise de l'état sur les
territoires avec la poursuite de ce que
j'ai amorcé depuis la crise des gilet
jaune et le grand débat c'est une
déconcentration de nos services avec
liar des réformes qui sont en train
qu'ils continuaient le prix aujourd'hui
mais nous déconcentre ont des services
pour qu'ils quittent paris et la région
parisienne et qu'ils aillent dans des
villes que ce soit des métropoles des
villes moyennes et des petites villes de
province et nous nous engageons
d'ailleurs à réouvrir se faisant des
sous préfectures c'est quoi l'enjeu pour
pour emmanuel macron pas oublier qu'on
parle d'eux des institutions parce qu'au
fond c'est d'abord l'angle mort du
premier mandat d' emmanuel macron s'il
devait y en avoir un deuxième parce qu
emmanuel macron avait promis un peu
moins et merveilles il a 5 ans des
réformes institutionnelles ambitieuses
sont et réduire le nombre de sénateurs
de député on devrait s'attendre devait
s'attacher très fortement à la question
de la restauration de la confiance dans
la dans l'action publique dans la
politique la proportionnelle passionnel
et finalement vous au bout du mandat on
voit que c'est l'un des la d aspect sur
lequel le mandat des manuels macroule au
moins tenu ses promesses quasiment pas
de promesses ont été tenues de ce point
de vue là et en même temps on voit bien
qu emmanuel macron sur ce sujet c'est un
sujet de prédilection pour lui il est
sorti lui-même de la machine de l'état
il était produit par la machine de la
haute fonction publique
c'est un sujet sur lequel il a eu
l'occasion de beaucoup s'exprimer à un
moment donné pendant toute la campagne
lorsque la république en marche a été
créé les fondateurs de la république en
marge disait quand on a frappé aux
portes des français on leur a demandé
qu'est-ce qui va pas en france la
première chose qui nous ont dit c'est la
politique et le système politique donc
et puis donc emmanuel macron assez
décevant là dessus donc on a eu aussi
pendant le mandat d' emmanuel macron
tournant intéressant qui au moment où on
va changer de premier ministre et où
edward fille va céder son poste à jean
castex ce qui est nommé pour faire du
territoire et c'est pas seulement pour
la crise qu vide c'est aussi pour
répondre à l'ensemble des crises gilet
jaune aussi on a vu la même dimension de
l'action publique territoriale compliqué
beaucoup d'élus locaux qu'ils on aurait
dû davantage nous faire confiance
pendant la crise qu'ovide la crise dg
les jeunes sur les ronds points est donc
un sujet qui est effectivement le niveau
de décision en france et vous voyez bien
que emmanuel macron ne peut pas être
absent de cette sédiments sur l'extrait
qu'on a choisi est très intéressant
parce qu'on a plusieurs références
directes indirectes à des problèmes
importants pour emmanuel macron y fait
référence au gilet jaune il dit depuis
que la crise du gilet jaune il vient
également sur un sujet qui lui tient à
coeur depuis plusieurs mois qui est la
réforme de l'état la réforme de la haute
fonction publique on va déconcentrer on
va remettre du fonctionnaires des
administrations centrales et locke sont
peu fonction publique pardon dans l'est
dans les territoires et c'est vrai que
pour le haut fonctionnaire qui l'est ce
débat permanent continue bien en france
décentralisation déconcentration
c'est un sujet qu'ils aiment bien
généralement les hauts fonctionnaires
c'est un explosé à sciences po ou à
l'oral de l'ena dont deux pas de là donc
ça va revenir
alexeï guerman est-ce que emmanuel
macron peut sortir d'une certaine façon
de son jacobinisme parce que ça a quand
même été un président jacobins oui c'est
très c'est très compliqué quand on est
en période de crise on voit bien que
d'arriver à insuffler parce que la
déconcentration évidemment c'est la
représentation de l'état dans les
territoires s'est pas laissé libre cours
par rapport à la décentralisation où on
a plus de liberté de manoeuvre donc déjà
de se positionner de ce point de vue là
c'est un marqueur fort par rapport à
d'autres à d'autres candidats après en
période de crise telles qu'on les a
vécus il est plus facile de faire de la
déconcentration que de la
décentralisation et donc on voit c'est
au-delà du tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que bruno cautrès venait de dire mais
mais mais de surcroît c'est plus facile
pour lui d'investir ce territoire en
période de crise de dire on a besoin de
représentation de l'état dans les
territoires et regardez par exemple je
fais juste un rapide pont quand on voit
le plan de relance qui a été mise en
oeuvre on voit qu'il y a eu des
nominations dans les territoires de pré
fête dédiée à la relance et ça c'est
typiquement le style d'outils dont le
gouvernement va avoir besoin pour
pouvoir faire finalement que le que le
citoyen puisse sentir au plus près de
lui les mesures macroéconomiques qui
sont impulsées par paris je crois que
c'est ça c'est ça le sujet pour vivre
vraiment une grande différence une une
grande élitiste déjà depuis hollande
[Musique]
ensemble et jacobin comme je suis
archevêque emmanuel macron a promis à la
corse ben voilà donc il n'est pas
jacobins il pas du tout jacobins il a
pris le système parce qu'il est comme ça
son truc c'est plutôt l'autonomie
regardait le deal qui l'a dépassé si on
en croit le canard enchaîné à trois
semaines des élections d'hier au corps
vous allez avoir l'autonomie en gros le
beurre et l'argent du beurre c'est tout
ou rien de chemins qui était notre
invité hier du monde dit que ce deal
c'était pas on n'en sais rien moi j'aime
beaucoup ariane chemin mais enfin je
veux dire par le révérend oui j'aime
beaucoup et elle connaît très bien la
corse mais il ya des gens qui
connaissent aussi bien la corse quel qui
disent oui c'est absolument états sont
de fait gérald darmanin a confié mais
l'udc à l'arraché les hier donc ça sert
à rien de dire que c'était pas vrai
gérald darmanin l'a fait je vois pas qui
parle d'autonomie si emmanuel macron ne
donne pas le taux sont bas il électoraux
donc le jacobinisme d'émana kron la
question institutionnelle pour moi la
grande déception ça était hollande sur
la question institutionnelle lui aussi
de faire sa réforme il ne l'a pas fait
la question et si même elle macron se
retrouve au second tour avec un candidat
d'extrême droite que ce candidat
d'extrême droite fait 44 45 % et que ce
candidat d'extrême-droite et bien se
retrouver avec cinq ou six députés on
fait comment vous comprenez la vraie
question institutionnelle c'est la
proportionnelle il a évacué je reconnais
qu'il en a parlé il est attaché la
prochaine ag et mais ça c'est le vrai
sujet comment on arrive à une
représentation générale et globale de ce
pays canton serge roques sans
jacobinisme j'y crois pas une minute non
si c'est il est très anglo-saxon en fait
en réalité un dernier mot puisque c'est
elle une des rumeur on va dire qu'ils
couraient depuis quelques jours sur sur
les législatives qui auraient pu être
avancé etc il l'a enterrée dans cette
conférence de presse il a fixé les dates
des élections j'ai trop de respect pour
les institutions pour jouer avec voilà
ce que le candidat macron a déclaré au
président qu'on va après on va terminer
là dessus merci beaucoup d'avoir partir
débat ici en plateau et jean daniel lévy
également en duplex